cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north vpn
pour accéder à une promo de 73% sur le
plan de deux ans et quatre mois
additionnels gratuits
rendez vous sur noir vbn point org slash
cyrus north ou utilisez simplement le
code cyrus north plus d'informations en
fin de vidéo
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous
connaissez le principe de ce format vous
envoyez vos histoires et des choses qui
vous sont arrivés et vous savez pas si
vous êtes des merdes ou non des choses
qui sont passés ou les envoyer avec un
service chiffre est je vous mets en
description du coup moi je reçois un mec
totalement anonyme préciser votre âge
aussi s'il vous plaît mais moi je lis
votre histoire et je vous juge
je vous jure je juge si oui ou non vous
êtes une merde mini précisions n'hésitez
pas à balancer des histoires aussi
qu'ils sont un peu insolite un peu
légères des choses de votre quotidien ce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'histoires qui sont
très fortes en émotions mais c'est aussi
un format de choses un petit peu plus
léger encore une fois si je dis que vous
êtes une merde ça veut dire que vous
êtes une mère dans toute votre vie
ces juges un événement particulier et
vice versa si je dis que vous n'êtes pas
une merde ça se trouve vous en êtes une
énorme dans votre vie en général risen
jamais même est ce que vous êtes des
merdes
[Musique]
suis-je une merde pour a fait d'autres
rencontres dans une optique amoureuse à
l'insu de mon copain et lui ont fait
croire pendant des années que je l'aimé
à direct direct on rentre dans les
relations amoureuses grands classiques
lorsque j'étais au collège je suis tombé
amoureux de mon meilleur ami très bien
de ce que je comprends donc c'est une
relation homosexuelle étant timide
maladif ayant du mal à exprimer mes
émotions je vais déclarer ma flamme sur
transformiste un jeu en ligne où l'on
incarne des souris super romantique en
gros ok on s'est rapidement mis ensemble
et nous sommes restés en couple pas loin
de 6 ans station 1 pour une première
relation c'est mon premier petit ami
bravo précise qu'à l'époque de notre
encontre et pendant toutes ces années je
me jean rey au féminin cette relation
était donc hétéro ah ok merci pour la
précision jusque là rien de dramatique
mais je me sens coupable sur certaines
choses au lycée déjà j'avais des doutes
sur notre relation
car rien ne s'était encore passé entre
nous ah oui vous et demi aux ensembles
au collège et jusqu'au lycée s'est rien
passé
ok j'ai très bien qu'il faut savoir être
patient que nous étions finalement
encore de petit gamin et que ses envies
peuvent prendre du temps à venir
cependant il n'y avait aucun signe
d'affection amoureuse entre nous mais à
part un petit bisou d'amoureux digne
d'enfants de primaire à chaque bonjour
et au revoir peut être un peu frustrant
nous ne nous en lassons pas nous ne nous
disions que très rarement je t'aime
il ne faisait pas de compliments il n'y
avait pas cette passion généralement
présente dans un jeune couple
pourtant je l'aimé à l'époque un jour un
garçon qui ignoraient ma situation m'a
proposé un rendez vous tu veux dire un
rendez vous j'ai accepté sur le coup
flatté que qu'ils s'intéressent à moi et
me fasse des compliments mais je me
senti extrêmement coupable et ensuite
annulé savoir que mon copain n'était pas
dans le même lycée que moi et n'a donc
jamais eu vent de cette histoire c'est
ce que tu penses mais il est là ce soir
cette situation à stagner jusqu'à la fin
du lycée où je suis parti faire mes
études supérieures dans mon
établissement j'ai à nouveau rencontrer
quelqu'un à temps mais what
attendez je percute cette situation à
stagner jusqu'à la fin du lycée à temps
sarkozy et demi ensemble collège
jusqu'au lycée rien tout lycée rien ah
ouais
dans mon établissement j'ai à nouveau
rencontrer quelqu'un j'ai d'abord pensé
que c'était une relation amicale mais
j'ai rapidement compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose entre nous comme j'étais
encore dans cette relation avec mon
copain j'ai commencé à prendre de la
distance avec ce garçon est en trop peur
que quelque chose se passe entre nous
mais mon amour
commencé à se détériorer sérieusement je
n'aimais plus qu'en tant qu'ami je te
dire un truc je suis pas surpris je suis
pas surpris l'année suivante ma
dépression a commencé à ma meilleure
amie était parti dans le sud et ne
restait plus que mon copain comme réelle
amitié proche de ma fille attendant je
comprends pas là vous êtes toujours pas
quelle personne n'avait le premier page
faut savoir qu'en plus de cette
dépression qui était déjà un réel frein
je suis anxieux social met donc très
difficile de faire de nouvelles
rencontres
quelle qu'elle soit la solitude me gagne
et je désespère en voyant notre relation
bien sûr j'aurais pu et d'ailleurs dû y
mettre un terme
mais j'avais peur de le perdre en tant
qu'ami d'autant plus que j'avais déjà pu
voir ses réactions négatives vis-à-vis
des ex de ses amis et de sa soeur à la
peur d'être seule je me suis donc
inscrit sur des sites de rencontres à
son insu et même eu quelques dates
j'avais l'impression de le tromper et me
sentais mal à ce propos même si je ne
les ai jamais embrassées eu de relation
avec pourtant cela me faisait aussi du
bien de partager des sensations avec
d'autres d'avoir un peu d'attention
d'autant plus que mon copain avait
tendance à ne parler que lui il a l'air
d'être un très gentil monsieur ce copain
après des années à faire semblant j'ai
finalement eu le courage de mettre un
terme à notre couple l'année dernière et
j'ai été très heureux de voir que nous
sommes restés amis
je n'ai cependant jamais raconté sa
rencontre à celui qui n'est désormais
plus que mon ami ne connaît son opinion
à propos du fait de tromper je pense
qu'il le prendrait mal même si nous
sommes plus ensemble crois même qu'il ne
sait même pas que j'étais en dépression
toutes ces années suis-je une merde pour
a fait d'autres rencontres dans une
optique amoureuse à l'insu de mon copain
dior fait croire pendant des années que
je l'aimais allah a pour moi non t'es
pas une merde en fait c'est pas une
merde tout simplement parce que mon déjà
est ce que c'est vraiment alors là il ya
discussion
est-ce que ses troupes aient pas ce que
je veux dire dans le sens où il ya des
gens pour qui prendre un verre avec
quelqu'un c'est forcément tromper turin
et les gens qui n'en faut aller plus
loin pour tromper toi t'as juste eu
quelques rendez-vous limite la démarche
de s'inscrire sur le site est plus
problématique est le rendez-vous en soi
j'imagine mais on n'est pas
face à toi qui enchaîne des relations
sexuelles je dire il ya un degré dans
les choses deviennent nuance il faut
nuancer les propos il faut nuancer les
propos même dans le fait de tromper
c'est difficile de dire c'est tout blanc
c'est tout noir disent ils de labelliser
d'un coup étiquette par la tromper parce
que tu as fais ça tu vois les situations
sont différentes les contextes sont
différents et c'est tard pour moi t'es
pas une merde c'est une relation
complexe
je n'ai pas les détails en fait donc je
ne sais pas qu'est ce qui a bloqué dans
votre relation je sais pas si vous avez
fait chacun des efforts et sait aussi
c'est que toi qui a fait des efforts
c'est que lui j'en sais rien toi dont il
manque certains détails en bref mais là
tu es que tu décris c'est pas ça que
j'appelle être une merde tu vois oui
évidemment
évidemment c'est mieux de ne pas faire
de dijk tu vois quand tu es en couple
mais là un couple comme ça on déjà tu as
un moment où j'en ris était plus
vraiment un couple
ouais tu vois pas ce que vous en donniez
le nom que ça l'était en réalité et avec
tout ce que vous avez vécu genre
collèges lycées en études supérieures
toujours rien passé ce à un âge où tu as
envie de découvrir donc découvrir les
gens en toi tu étais en dépression tu te
sens tu es seul tu te sentais pas
forcément soutenu et c'est par ton
copain il est étalé besoin d'aller
chercher un truc était allé le chercher
tu vois et même en étant allé le
chercher tes rester hyper clean
donc non je ne pense pas que tu admires
et j'espère qu'aujourd'hui tout va bien
pour toi suivent une mère pour arles
oublié l'anniversaire de mon ami et pour
ne pas y être allé
j'ai été absent absente pendant une
semaine le soir de mon retour doit être
organisé l'anniversaire d'une de mes
amies n'étant pas sûr de mon état de
fatigue à la fin de la semaine
j'ai préféré prévenir
que je ne serait possiblement pas là à
cette soirée une seconde soirée a alors
été organisée une semaine après mon
retour car ma présence son insert compté
pour elle à la pression à la pression
j'ai eu la date longtemps à l avance
mais je ne vais pas noté peut-être là ma
première heure ah bah oui l'erreur
on le voit venir gros comme une maison
au cours de cette semaine j'ai été très
occupé et étant à c'était en l'air cette
soirée d'anniversaire mais complètement
sorti de la tête le soir de mon retour
j'étais comme je le pensais trop crevé
pour sortir et suis resté chez moi pour
me reposer mais sans prévenir mon ami de
mon absence à sa première soirée
deuxième erreur alors en début de
semaine suivante je discutais avec un
groupe d'amis
l'un d'eux habite à l'autre bout de la
france et avait décidé de nous rendre
visite le week-end qui arrive donc celui
où prenait place la soirée d'hier
n'ayant pas vu ses amis irl in real life
depuis longtemps ayant très envie de la
revoir je leur propose de faire la
soirée chez moi avec l'argument que j'ai
un grand appartement
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas de mes
autres amis du groupe habitant la même
ville
ah ouais donc non seulement en fait tu
vas pas la soirée tapote mais en plus
fait contre soirée chez toi la soirée
s'organise bien au cours de la semaine
jusqu'au moment délicat où je me rends
compte que j'avais promis à ma présence
à l'anniversaire de mon ami je me sens
vraiment gêné de devoir faire un choix
entre ces deux soirées l'une où j'ai
promis à ma présence et l'autre avec des
amis que je n'avais pas vu depuis un an
et qui se passe chez toi j'ai malgré
tout choisi de continuer d'organiser la
soirée chez moi avec mon groupe d'amis
car cela faisait trop longtemps que je
les avais pas vu et que je vois mon
autre ami assez régulièrement
bien évidemment on a mis a été et est
toujours très remonté contre moi pour
leur a fait faux bond une deuxième fois
je suis moi même très tracassés d'avoir
eu à faire ce choix et j'aurais bien
entendu participé aux deux soirées si
j'en avais eu la possibilité suis-je une
merde oui oui t'es une merde on donne
une date d'anniversaire ben tu la note
tu t'assures que celle d'après qui
organisait pour moi tu as tu la note
bien aussi quoi clairement on imprime
l'organisation ici maintenant je sais
pas si ta pote verra cette vidéo
peut-être qu'elle reconnaîtra cette
histoire mais si c'est le cas vas-y
pardonne la part d'hommes l'ast est ce
que je suis une mère pour voir refuser
un stagiaire au dernier moment
aïe aïe aïe salut cyrus salut à toi je
suis doctorants dans un laboratoire
public tous les ans les équipes de
recherches prennent en stage des
étudiants en master 2 et valident leur
stage de fin d'études et le labo gagne
un peu de main d'oeuvre est donc demandé
à ma directrice de thèse de recruter un
étudiant de master pour un stage de 6
mois elle m'a dit oui et je me suis
occupé de publier notre annonce dans les
généralités et écoles que mois après
nous avons un candidat sérieux appelons
le bob hawke et quoi l'avoir reçue en
entretien ma directrice de thèse me dis
que je peux le prendre en stage si je le
souhaite
c'est à moi de décider jeudi donc à bob
que normalement on va pouvoir le prendre
en stage mais je lui demande d'attendre
un petit peu avant d'envoyer sa
convention stage car je dois vérifier
auprès du service rh qu'on a bien
l'argent pour cela mais qu
habituellement ça ne pose pas de
problème on ait eu un changement
budgétaire au dernier moment
c'est pour ça que j'ai vérifié avant de
m'engager définitivement quelques jours
après ma directrice de thèse m'annonce
qu'elle a reçu une autre candidature
appelons-la alice alice est en train de
doubler bob tu dis je me suis déjà
engagé auprès de bob et qu'on va devoir
le dire que le stage est déjà pourvue ma
directrice de thèse me dit qu'elle a
déjà convenu un entretien avec sept
secondes candidats peuvent agacer car
elle m'avait dit que je pouvais choisir
ce qui est impliqué d'être transparent à
des futurs candidats et je me retrouve
malgré moi en porte-à-faux bien d'accord
avec toi
l'entretien d' alice se passe très bien
à yaya s'arrêtait plus simple si ça se
passait mal et elle est objectivement
meilleur que bob mais je m'étais engagé
auprès depuis ma directrice de thèse me
dis que je peux choisir l'étudiant que
je veux a donc elle maintient son truc
auquel j'essaie de privilégier les
compétences et panda l'isthme à athus de
travail tout seul
malheureux il se travaille elle me
répond qu'à ceux de voir d'autres offres
de stage avant d'accepter hall alors
alice alice tu passes devant bob déjà
mollo l'asticot alice entre temps j'ai
la réponse des rh
on a assez d'argent pour un stage et je
décide de ne pas dire à bob qu'on a
assez d'argent ni lui dire qu'on hésite
maintenant avec une autre candidate pour
garder un plan b c'est que la situation
allait vite se résoudre mais ça traîne
en longueur
après au moins un mois un mois mais
s'est passé quoi pendant un mois alice
canalis qui a fait traîner un truc alice
accepte le stage et j'ai dit à bob pour
ne pas pouvoir le prendre je n'assume
pas du tout et lui dit que finalement on
n'a pas l'argent et en plus je le met
dans la merde car il reste très peu de
temps pour trouver un stage alors cyrus
est ce que je suis une merde ah non mais
j'étais derrière toi jusqu'au moment où
tu as dit vas-y tu sais quoi
fat bob je prends alice et j'attends un
mois pour et attend un mois gros pas
cool c'est pas cool pour petit bob la
pop bob bob ici est pris à temps s'y est
pris tôt et ça l'a foutu dans la merde
près c'est une bonne leçon pour bob
parce que là bob du coup il ya 10
rebonds il fera plus jamais confiance à
une entreprise ou un labo où ce que tu
veux c'est fini fini bob il a plus
confiance dans le système c'est sûr et
il en a fait une belle leçon pour alice
aussi de lui dire analystes en fait là
jusque temps pour donner ta réponse
remettre un ultimatum à alice à la fin
de cet ultimatum soit alice elle a eu
l'audace d'y aller et des rouies et
let's go soit alice ai dit non et tu
prends bob un vaste secteur a dû faire
quoi juste mettre un ultimatum un moins
gros mais ces doctorants laboratoires
publics
donc allez vraiment toute petite merde
est-ce que je suis une mère peut avoir
insulté un des meilleurs amis de mon
conjoint un des plus grands amis de mon
conjoint a commencé à quelques années
devient extrêmement violent avec moi
chai est pour l'instant tu as bien fait
pour l'instant de ce que j'ai lu
l'histoire tu as bien fait j'ai
aujourd'hui je vis avec mon conjoint
depuis trois ans et à chameau qui vient
chez nous ils m'envoient beaucoup de
pick plus ou moins désagréable aide qui
fout quoi ça secoue et kif ces
réflexions sont progressivement devenus
assez raciste chinoise ping pong etc
ping pong et même si je faisais tous les
efforts possibles pour être gentil avec
lui ma patience atteignent et céline
alain fauquet venu il a sorti une
réflexion globalement moins pire que les
autres mais je l'insulté et je lui dis
que s'il recommençait encore une fois il
sortait de chez moi il est parti
s'invite à près de colère et n'est
jamais revenue chez nous et je
culpabilise un peu que mon conjoint ne
le voit plus depuis
excuse-moi excuse moi mais le conjoint
est fait quoi dans l'histoire au le
conjoint l'aria ton pote qui parlent mal
le avec ta meuf là pour moi le conjoint
devrait aider dans cette situation si tu
devrais pas la gérer cette situation
et sinon c'est pas une merde t'es pas
une merde c'est le mec il est là et tu
parles mal et s'est dit des trucs que tu
aimes pas séché watts
ciao arrivederci après par contre moi je
trouve que le conjoint est loin de moi
l'idée de vouloir le mettre dans la
sauce on lui demande pas de choisir
entre sa meuf et son pote mais on peut
lui demander de
de recadrer ses potes quand ça va pas
quoi aurait-il pas une mère tel que tu
me décrit là tu vois ça se trouve si on
écoutait ses insultes on serait tous là
à dire bah c'est pas une insulte c'est
pas je sais pas je suis par là tu vas je
suis pas dans le gp assister au truc
mais ça se trouve c'est hyper
susceptible
je ne sais pas donc en fait je reviens
sur ce que j'ai dit
j'ai dit que c'était pas une merde mais
c'est vrai que sans avoir les phrase
exacte je me base que sur ce que tu dis
toi y'a pas de souci ça manque de fel ça
manque de factuel dans tous les cas ça
mérite une peut-être conversation que le
conjoint c'est fou j'adore comme quand
il ya une réflexion qui se déroule en
fait on se déroulant s contredit j'adore
quand c'est comme ça un petit côté eagle
suis-je une merde pouvoir coucher avec
la meuf vierge de mon pote l'anecdote
remonte à l'époque du lycée
ma deuxième année de secondes
précisément j'étais plus âgé que mes
camarades car j'avais redoublé et je
fêtais mes 18 ans cette année là j'avais
un très bon ami à moi dans la classe qui
sortait avec une fille deux classes
faisait maintenant quelques temps qu'ils
étaient ensemble et n'avait toujours pas
couché ensemble
il était vierge tous les deux
apparemment tout le monde le savait
cependant il nous avait fait part d'être
pressé par rapport à ça et qu'il
risquait de bientôt franchir le cap
ensemble le jour on aère sers de mes 18
ans où j'ai organisé une norme fait dans
une salle louée à cet effet j'avais
invité pas mal d'amis dont mes camarades
de classe elle est venue lui n'était pas
disponible
ça sent la merde la soirée se passe je
suis alcoolisées très agréable à la
voilà ça met la faute sur l'alcool tout
de suite tout de suite on te vois venir
on doit venir au point que j'en sors
prendre l'air dehors dit donc
alcoolisées au point où tu dois les deux
ordres
moi je tenais pas du tout debout en fait
j'ai du mal manger par terre au québec
était quand même pas mal alcoolisées je
rappelle évidemment que l'abus de
l'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
buvez avec modération ça rien de se
mettre une énorme casse
un ami vient me voir essaie de m'aider
les classiques conseils de gens
pourraient aller vomir un coup et ses
amis les vrais je n'arrive pas à vomir
alors je décide de m'allonger sur le dos
pour être à l'aise et pouvoir bien
respirer à ce moment là la fille arrive
et me glisse dessus et perd sa virginité
c'est fou ce qui à ce moment là la fille
arrive et commence directement à me
chauffer mes jambes me chauffe est
vraiment vraiment vraiment beaucoup mon
pote qui voient ça s'écarte gêné et
amusé aussi mais surtout gêné moi je
suis totalement ailleurs je ne réalise
pas bien ce qui se passe on s'embrasse
puis elle m'aide à me relever et me
guident vers les toilettes on s'enferme
et on sombre aux vices de l'adultère aya
watts et grosses étaient consentants ou
pas du coup ce que tes terres arrachées
et était ok etc ce qui se passe tu dis
aussi on s'embrasse et pas elle
m'embrasse du coup j'imagine que tu
étais ok je rappelle voilà je rappelle
que quand on est face à quelqu'un qui
est sous l'effet de l'alcool notamment à
des stades avancés comme ça la question
se pose il faut faut se rendre sur et
voilà normalement on n'est pas dans un
état où on peut donner son consentement
je rappelle qu'elle était vierge en
couple avec un ami que cet ami était
vierge et précède sauter le pas comme ça
on s'en souvient vraiment c'était
construit je pense que ce sont des
circonstances aggravantes dont je le
rappelle au tac est pas vraiment on
l'avait on l'avait bien souligner tous
je pense que tout le monde et s'en est
bien soutenu tout le monde est au
courant des lendemains ça fait le tour
de toutes nos connaissances le mec est
au courant et c'est bien le lundi
reprise des cours est là le gros malaise
quand il s'agit de revoir mon ami plus
ton ami quoi j'imagine étant même
faisait la gueule et moi je savais plus
où mettre à la ils vont être
dégoûtés le gars maintenant est là et la
meuf elle en pense quoi tout ça je suis
sorti une semaine avec la fille mais je
ressentais rien pour elle aille donc la
fille ne l'aimé où on ne l'aimé pas on
perd l appât essaie de rattraper le truc
avec lui j'imagine je pense que je suis
sorti un peu par dépit déjà car j'ai
remarqué qu'en fait je lui plaisais
depuis déjà longtemps et ensuite parce
qu'après avoir trahi mon ami comme ça je
me disais que c'était encore pire que ce
soit juste une coucherie d'un soir
plutôt que quelque chose de sérieux
comprend au bout d'une semaine c'était
trop gênant je ne sais même pas quoi
dire à sa fille pour qui je ne
ressentais rien prend finalement la
décision de la quitter j'ai au moins
là-bas bilité c'est de le faire depuis
voit en lui donnant rendez-vous pour lui
annoncer mon ami ne m'a jamais reparler
aujourd'hui je ne sais même pas ce qu'il
fait et où il est en revanche revu la
fille à plusieurs reprises dans des
coucheries sans lendemain pour pendant
plusieurs heures suis-je une grosse
merde non au début je pensais la grosse
merde c'est la meuf là dans l'histoire
je crois s'il devait y en avoir une
parce que moi ce qui me gêne dans cette
histoire c'est que la meuf elle a abusé
d'un état de ton état de fragilité
en fait si tu étais pas saoul je pense
que jamais même site avait chauffé
jamais d'israël et on avait donc non
c'est chiant c'est chiant je comprends
assez chiante a perdu un pote dans
l'histoire etc
tu as aidé à une tentation j'espère que
tu as pris du plaisir si vous être revus
plusieurs fois pendant plusieurs années
pour coucher ensemble c'est que c'était
cool
j'imagine ces histoires qui arrivent
mais pour moi le fait que l'élément
déclencheur fait que c'était elle
l'initiatrice du truc que toi tu était
alcoolisé que elle elle restait avec le
gars alors qu'en fait c'est toi qui lui
plaisait et ce qui explique d'ailleurs
pourquoi peut-être elle a rien fait avec
le gard peut-être qu'elle voulait se
garder pour toi tu vois en fait pour moi
t'es pas une merde
suis-je une merde si j'ai voulu balancer
mon ami à son mec qu'elle trompe depuis
des années salut elle fit et sa lucia
pour cet épisode là c'est pas alfie qui
fait les histoires c'est sommes donc on
est trois là on est trois sur le truc
qui atom qui choisit l'histoire moi qui
réagit dessus alfie qui les montrent
toutes une équipe car déjà juste marrer
sur le titre un sujet une merde si j'ai
voulu balancer mon ami à son mec elle
tremble
là c'est le dilemme qu'on a tous pas
envie d'avoir quoi classique dilemme qui
connaissait cet ami depuis neuf ans
pendant ces neuf années cet ami avait
plusieurs copains et les a tous trompés
encore plus jeune je n'approuvais pas
ses agissements mais je me disais juste
que ce n'était pas mes affaires et où je
n'avais pas à la juger ce n'était pas
des relations sérieuses on était jeune
donc ça me paraissait mon âge j'étais la
seule fille qui ne la jugez pas donc
j'étais la seule amie à qui elle
racontait tout ces tromperies et elle me
considérait comme sa meilleure amie
je peux comprendre je crois parce que je
j'ai déjà connu des gens comme ça un
jour elle s'est mise en couple avec un
garçon elle ne l'a pas trompé pendant
toute la première année de leur relation
il s'était fait trompé par son ex et
avait donc de gros problème de confiance
elle a donc dû gagner sa confiance
pendant un an et une fois qu'elle a
obtenu elle a commencé à le tromper avec
plusieurs autres mecs cools bonne
ambiance là au nom le bon couple quoi ça
tu me fais confiance maintenant super je
peux sortir voir mes amis sans que tu
sois inquiet génial tu vois ta pas
t'inquiéter mon amour à plus tard je lui
ai servi plusieurs fois d'alibi et elle
m'a demandé avant si j'étais d'accord
j'ai toujours dit oui parce que je me
disais que tout ça ce n'était pas mes
affaires mais si c'était pas tes
affaires pourquoi tu sert d'alibi alors
en fait en servant d'alibi
ça vient un peu tes affaires non je vais
après ça dépend chacun mais je me pose
la question
question rires mais je disais quand même
que je pensais qu'elle devait arrêter
son jugement porté sur elle mais plutôt
questionnons l'amour a été de ça elle ne
prenait pas trop les choses au sérieux
et pour elle ce n'était pas grave tant
qu'il ne savait pas comment bas
aujourd'hui je comprends pas
à 20 ans c'était pas pareil quand
j'avais 20 ans c'était pas pareil je
voulais comprendre ce genre de truc
quand j'ai essayé de la convaincre de
tout lui avouer elle refusait
catégoriquement parce qu'elle pensait
que s'ils apprenaient il ne la
partageraient jamais les années ont
passé et continue à le tromper et lui ne
savait toujours rien j'espère qu'ils
avaient été des capotes
j'ai eu un premier déclic quand j'ai
demandé un soir mon ami pourquoi elle ne
préférait pas le quitter et être
célibataire aux poires couché avec qui
elle voulait librement et qu'elle a ri
en me disant que c'était plus drôle
excitant de tromper quelqu'un ah ouais
non mais c'est chaud là mais on est où
là je commençais à me sentir complice
coupable de garder ce secret en plus
c'est lourd comme secret ça parce que
c'est normal c'est comme ça d'une
relation sérieuse et où elle me
racontait tout en détails
et bien sûr je devais garder cet énorme
secret alors qu'elle était incapable de
garder les miens et a brisé plus avoir
la confiance je suis pas surpris parce
que elle a brisé la confiance de son mec
déjà donc la tienne aussi j'ai aussi
commencé à réaliser que cette amitié
était très inégale et toxique j'ai
toujours là pour elle
je l'écoutais toujours mais l'inversé
n'était pas vrai et surtout sa relation
avec son mec commençait à devenir
vraiment sérieuse ils ont emménagé
ensemble
oh là là aiment parler de ses envies de
mariage et de bébé oh là là haut mais
quelle horreur mais quelle horreur
1 c'est horrible j'ai mal au ventre la
vie de ma mère j'ai mal au ventre
bref je me disais qu'elle appelle son ex
aurait voulu voir la vérité avant de me
marier et de faire des enfants à
quelqu'un je me disais qu'ils avaient le
droit de savoir la vérité et de faire
son choix ensuite je ne voulais pas
trahir mon ami mais j'étais la seule au
courant de tout donc la seule à pouvoir
le dire à son copain j'étais vraiment
dans un dilemme c'est le mot que
j'utilise et à la haye
c'est un dilemme qui nous pend au nez à
beaucoup de gens oh pas moi mais
des périodes de ma vie peut-être et
encore heureusement là autour de moi
m'ont esafe quant à quelqu'un comme ça
dans son entourage grâce et pesant c'est
pesant un jour sur un coup de tête après
la confidence de tromperie de trop pour
moi j'ai envoyé un message à mon ami
disons que je voulais que son mec soit
au courant à ton ami elle a dû vivre ça
comme un missile j'ai ensuite dit que si
elle ne disait pas je le ferai ouch
ouf où ça devient excitant oulala et là
j'ai découvert une autre facette de mon
ami bah oui ah bah oui la mauvaise et
manipulatrice jusqu'au chantage au
suicide
ses amis m'ont envoyé des messages pour
essayer de me convaincre de ne rien dire
je me suis fait insulter de tous les
noms et menacé de mort et de me faire
frapper
lequel en premier du coup parce que si
les menaces de se faire frapper arrive
après les menaces de mort fait des
plaisanteries on fait des petites vannes
chantage au suicide de leur part aussi
avec les potes
il disait que si elle ou son mec se
suicider ce serait de ma faute parce que
j'allais détruire leur vie enfin qui est
vrai que les 'petits' loi nous aussi on
va se suicider mais aucun sens strict
elle a même réussi à retourner mes
propres parents contre - what we les
parents qu'ils font là dedans les
parents pour tous les gens à qui elle
avait parlé j'étais la grande méchante
de l'histoire parce qu'elle a minimisé
en leur faisant croire qu'elle avait
trompé son monde pas juste une fois en
soirée genre juste un bisou sous l'effet
de l'alcool
et vas-y tu veux jouer à sa meuf du
moins tout le monde en minimisant on va
dire la vérité et on va voir qui gagne
après blague à part sur les chantage au
suicide la faut faire attention quand
même moi c'est le genre de cas où
georges essaie d'appeler un
professionnel voilà voilà
ok la personne elle m'a dit ça machin
qu'est ce que je sens et faire mon ami
m'a demandé de lui laisser du temps de
le dire à son copain avant une date
précise
j'ai accepté puisque je pensais que
c'était mieux pour tout le monde si
c'était elle qui lui disent elle m'a
fait croire qu'elle lui avait dit qu'il
avait quitté qu'elle ne voulait donc
plus jamais entendre parler de moi et
elle m'a bloqué partout j'ai appris peu
de temps après que c'est évidemment faux
elle lui avait rien dit elle m'avait
menti pour être sûr que je n'avais pas
le dire à son blanc est cette personne
et les el helou avant cette personne là
à partir de là j'ai pensé que c'était
trop tard revenir à la charge
hors effet pensé que j'avais fait ça
dans le seul but de lui faire du mal
donc j'ai laissé tomber ouais
ouais j'aurais laissé tomber aussi je
pense parce que aller au delà de ça ça
aurait été sortir de ton rôle je crois
enfin moi je leur ai vécu comme ça je
pense c'est s'est passé il ya plus de
deux ans j'ai toujours un peu sur la
conscience parce que finalement ils sont
toujours ensemble et son copain est
sûrement toujours pas au courant
voilà je te laisse juger est ce que je
fais une meilleure pour rentrer mon ami
ont peut-être sujets de merde pour ne
pas l'avoir dit à son copain je pense
que tu es une merde ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre
je pense que tu as fait ce qui était
dans son rôle tu as dit que voilà tu
pouvais plus accepter cette relation
avec son ami tu pouvais plus accepter ce
mensonge que tu trouves tu trouves ça
normal qu'elle le sache que son copain
le sache
la meuf du coup tu as éjecté de sa vie
et en même temps ce n'est pas une
justicière tueur pour moi tu as fais ce
que tu avais à faire
on espère tous très fort que le copain
on va un jour le savoir mais je crois
que c'est pas à toi lui dire mais je
suis curieux parce que ça veut dire dans
les commentaires ci est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi sur le fait que voilà
elle est restée dans son rôle entre
guillemets genre dépasser ce rôle c'est
trop en tout cas dans tous les cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que t'es pas une mère
pour un trail ton ami parce qu'en fait
il ya un moment où gioria ton ami es
athée valeur tu vois si ne pas trahir
ton ami ça veut dire trahir tes valeurs
il ya un problème je vois ce que je veux
dire et donc mieux vaut ne pas se trahir
soi est très fière ton ami que l'
inverse
tu vois donc c'est juste que c'est pas
que tu as trahi ton ami c'est qu'en fait
il ya un moment où genre les valeurs de
ton ami de sa grande collecte et valeurs
donc est-ce que c'était encore ton ami à
ce moment là je suis pas sûr je me suis
encore une fois régalé en lisant vos
histoires quoi vous je vous présente
encore quelqu'un je reviens et c'est
cyrus north bpm en open est un vpn est
secousse excuses à un vpn virtual
private networks sas a grosso modo à
deux choses principales la première
c'est en gros naviguer de manière
sécurisée sur le web
lorsque vous êtes dans des wifi non
sécurisés par exemple
un restaurant café un aéroport etc et
que vous êtes dans des sites qui sont en
http là en gros toutes les données qui
transitent peuvent être interceptés par
un hacker pas si vous avez un vpn
deuxième raison très pratique si vous
voulez faire croire que vous êtes à
l'étranger quoi ça sert de faire croire
qu'on à l'étranger a par exemple sur
netflix ou quoi on veut accéder au
catalogue américain
on a un vpn on se loge depuis les us et
c'est parfait moi même je m'en sers pour
certains sites qui ne sont pas
accessibles en france par exemple et
donc j'utilise des vpn pour accéder à
ces sites là je vous le dis direct à la
question suis-je une merde d'aller sur
ce site la réponse est non c'est un
service qui est disponible à la fois sur
smartphone sur tablette ordinateur vous
pouvez avoir plusieurs appareils en même
temps tout de suite une image de moi
qu'il utilise sur smartphone est donc là
admettons j'aurais de me connecter en
france bîmes quick connect et c'est
super league par ruben je peux aussi par
exemple choisir de me connecter depuis
les etats unis
hop et un service après-vente 24h 24 7
jours sur 7 en france elle est garantie
satisfait ou remboursé dans les 30 jours
et en allant sur nord vpn point org
slash six ans lorsque vous avez 73 % de
réduction sur le plan de deux ans et
quatre mois offerts
vous pouvez aussi utiliser le code
circonstances merci à eux 2 sponsorisé
cette vidéo j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu - c'est toujours un régal
voilà de lire vos histoires etc alors
you c'est le sens du montage qui n'a pas
monté cette vidéo d'ailleurs juste pour
dire la semaine prochaine mercredi 30
juin je serai en live sur twitter
à 22 heures soyez là on va parler
d'échec scolaire de reconversion et tout
ça sera un live fait en partenariat avec
open classroom la première heure je
faire du riz actes sur des reportages
des documents etc
ça va être cool et la deuxième heure
soit être une table ronde avec des
étudiants une formatrice pour qu'on
parle de cette thématique de
reconversion et du sceqe scolaire va
être formé et où les attend mercredi
prochain à 20,2 à sur ma chaîne twitch
foutues quand tv ce lhc vos sens et
europe associée aux du passé la semaine
prochaine je sors ce qu'on appelle une
faq c'est à dire que je vais répondre à
vos questions les questions sur l'avenir
de la chaîne sur sur moi sur ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers mois etc
je récupérerai vos questions sur
instagram et sur twitter sur ces deux
plateformes
je ferai des annonces séparées et je
vous expliquerai comment poser vos
questions voilà la semaine prochaine
c'est une vidéo spéciale faq et je vous
préviens dès maintenant parce que vous
regardez etes-vous des merdes
cet été je vais en sortir non pas un par
mois mais deux par mois et j'espère que
cette information vous fait plaisir je
vous embrasse très fort love peace et
ciao
[Musique]